welcome to this video what does he have
myanmar see traveling okay this is me
playing Grand Master Shi blah originally
from Germany but now he only located in
in Thailand so 92 that's not very active
but of course player very solid opening
I played that too quickly he can now
take on be aid and give me that a check
their on b5 and let him in little let
letting him take on a 5 is also pretty
awkward okay yeah of course
now I just see 5 come on chat why did I
play that too quickly i mean it's
totally harmless opening my white but
you don't have to play instant moves
okay what a disaster
yeah I've got a bishop pair hooray
hooray rain rain but okay maybe I can
play a quick be 6 cm he's out for c4
that's probably a pretty good decision
okay I have to do something drastic him
anyway maybe ego ce6 now I could have
just taken c5 what am I doing here are
come on come on concentrate focus I
could have just taken c5 and I'm not so
in such a bad shape why am I gifting him
this point here this is just nonsense
awful maybe I shouldn't play while being
on drugs oh no it's no not of nowhere I
know cocaine or anything it's just that
um I had some pretty painful dentist
meeting and taking some painkillers it's
nothing nothing too strong but it's
probably not not great for your chest
playing abilities as we are witnessing
damn awful what an awful game I could
have just taken on c5 and I don't think
I'm in such bad shape would be weird if
I ever would be I can't even go dear for
now
I'd be happy to get into an endgame here
and we'll just cancel of course
I really hate to give them points is
this kind of playing idiotic moves and
giving the opponent just just just the
win with with idiotic plane
he had to do absolutely nothing to win
this game I just tended to handed it to
him
Jim queen before wins many things win
check check
just try to get to play the most
confusing moves check hmm seems that I'm
not immediately checkmated at least
check oh maybe I am I didn't see that
one coming she for checkmate I mean
sometimes you have games where you think
you'll feel completely out of out of out
of it oh my god yeah well see 5 is
totally unnecessary you can do whatever
here we should be six or so and equal
check yeah here I'm just in bad shape
but now he played wuxi one and I can
just take here I mean this is just I'm
just okay I think this is bad but you go
have six king of seven I mean this is
totally ok for black the engine gives
0.2 instead I I completely I mean I had
planned to play b6 on moves like before
and I didn't think of Roxy 1 and this is
just utterly idiotic I mean b6 is just
the worst what was I thinking I think
nothing probably yeah here you just just
lost him it's nothing nothing to say
about it it's just damn lost check yeah
it was kind of funny to the sequence
check check check mate yeah okay how'd
that one under playing uh yeah where was
that called edu is driving under the
influence are playing under the
influence pui ok anyway yeah thanks for
watching